hey guys Mary here and you might
remember last week I played an evil
horror game called layers of fear budget
doll heads
well today I'm going to be unboxing the
press box that they sent us it looks
like some kind of evil man's painters
kits so we'll open it right up and get
into it says right there what if you
fail it looks super evil it's got some
goodies in it the first thing is this
package that has some string in it looks
like a letter we'll open up a letter
first it's got a wax seal on it says my
esteemed colleague now this is obviously
some extra lore for anyone who remembers
the lead character is a painter who's
kind of going insane so it's a little
bit more lore I won't read all of it for
you and then it comes with a
self-portrait this is pretty interesting
of him going mad that's really cool it's
got a little stand so I can stay on your
desk now we're getting really into some
of the gross stuff in this box
children's bedtime stories Henriette the
duck not content just splashing away and
the river is she liked
tearing out hearts and chewing on livers
this is not a normal bedtime story the
end a Little Red Riding Hood oh my god
so he's eating her I think you can see
where this is going I think these are a
lot of the old-school tales you might
remember but they're way darker versions
they're pretty pretty evil looking so
nightmares for day is another secret
letter which you find throughout the
games that's really interesting this
looks like a newspaper clipping
a once great artist new painting left
out of galleries so he's kind of getting
into the lore that the painter is kind
of lost his way a grand opening in
flames a fire that kills dozens in
injures hundreds at a galleries more
about his his fall from grace here oh my
gosh we're starting to get there's lots
of newspaper clippings thank so here we
go we're getting into some of the
physical objects some candles
what paint brush that's been worn away
and now we get into some of the creepier
stuff some old photos these are getting
really gross a mousetrap oh this one's
gross it's a lock of hair and I think
you might be real so upsetting
Henry Marvin MD relationship counselor
Oh matchbook now these are really gross
here's one this is a vial that says not
just any canvas it's really stressful
looking so I will not give away what
this is but if you watch any of the
Let's Plays you should know oh gosh
undercoat bone white it looks like
there's a little bone in there and the
third vial is for final touches and it
looks like a cut finger it's really good
so three vials and then some other
knickknacks in here I think this is the
tooth oh Lord
a baby's arm in case you want those in
your house and then a lot of extra
pieces of lore pharmacy slip all sorts
of notes to the daughter a photo of the
mother and her baby another photo of the
mother with the baby but it's a little
creepier lots of lore and a lot of these
you see in
themselves these are images the
prosthetic Snatchers my damn leg because
the character has a limp in the game I
think they have a prosthetic leg which
you can feel when you're walking around
so that's pretty much it in this box
lots of lots of creepy knickknacks to
unravel a little unsettling but it's
great to see the extra lore that goes
behind this really interesting horror
game so if you guys like this you might
be interested in the game and you can
play it layers of fear it's coming out
on ps4 Xbox one PC Mac and Linux On
February 16th thank you guys for
watching I hope you guys don't have any
nightmares